only 1% of tax returns are flagged for
audits the rest skate safely by here are
six red flags that could up your chances
of being water number one your numbers
don't match what were your income your
numbers have to match what the IRS
received probably not a problem if you
get a w-2 but if you get 1099 get paid
in cash or have income from other
sources make sure the amount you have on
the forms matches what has been reported
number two be generous
give to charity but don't overdo it know
how much others in your income level
give the IRS does give too much an
eyebrows will raise number three be
super wealthy the IRS is now auditing
one out of every eight tax payers who
reported over 1 million dollars in
income the more you make the more Uncle
Sam wants to know how he's getting his
cut number 4 have a home office be
prepared to back up every home office
deduction with how you used it for your
work and if you're a salaried employee
bar is even higher number 5 use round
numbers round numbers are great for math
problems they are not so great for
deductions be precise use exact amounts
rounding is clue the IRS that you can't
support the deduction with paperwork
right answer is 9 number 6 get ratted
out the IRS gives snitches a reward
don't brag or give someone a reason to
turn you in for tax fraud